ゆる～くスポーツでもしましょうか
と思ったんですけども
我々は運動不足なので
過度な運動をすると
マジなほうでね
過度な運動してしまうと死んじゃうので
ちょっとこうなんか
気楽にできるスポーツはないかと
思ったんですけども
昔スポーツテストってやりましたよね
スポーツテストの中でハンドボール投げ
あ、
バリバリ見えてたわｗｗ
スポーツテストの中で　こうなんか気軽にできるスポーツ
といったらなんでしょう？
やーもうそれはシャトルラン
ハンドボール投げを今回してみようと思います
巻き尺とか結構がちで測ろうと思ってて
ハンドボール投げでちょっと実際に我々の腕の強さを
ちょっと測ろうと思います
力無いように見れてたぶん割と強いんで
こう構えてたら腕使うよね
割とたぶんね腕の力には自信があると思うんで
シンプルにちょっと我々のハンドボールの記録を今回測ってみようと思います
えっと、高校一年生の男子の平均記録が
高校二年生男子が
高校三年生がピークで
要するにたぶん27ｍ超えたら
男としては立派なんじゃねえかという感じらしいです
室伏選手のスポーツテストは高校時代
おかしいでしょｗｗｗ
もうメーター超えちゃうからね（笑）
大学一年生の男子平均が
で、大学二年生が
ちょと弱くなっちゃった
で、大学三年生からは記録がないらしいです
で、一応参考に女子は
女子はずっと14か15ｍなんだ
女子は14、15ｍくらいが平均です
女子高生、女子大生ぐらいで
なので我々はひとまず
はい、０からスタートして27mはだいたいですね
遠くでぇぇす
０から始まって
たぶんあそこら辺が27m
あそこが男子の平均でございます
というわけで1投目まずはまさきいきましょう
はーい　頼んだぞ
ちなみにまさきさん目標は？
目標は、、、
平均狙いにいくのね
ここが26だ！
遠くね？
いや、いけるいける
じゃあいきます
え？え？
わあ！
え、結構いったんじゃない？
ここでしょ、ここだから
あっ！
２２．
結果出ました！結果出ました！結果出ました！
速報です！
結果は…
22.7m！
やあばくない！？
や、でも運動してないからね
え、反省点としては
たぶん、これ
いｍ…
ここが27
うわ、絶対いかねーわこれ
ではどうぞ
いきまーす
なるほどなるほど
なるほどなッ！
おっけいおっけいここら辺ね
果たして、記録は！
あ、でも　でも？
出ました！速報です！速報出ました！
記録は…
26.7m！
や、でも平均平均
平均だよ
まじ？
いけてる？
いや、よくやったよくやった
いくぞぉぉ！
よっし、いきます
いきますよ？
へーい
ここっすね
７ですね
速報でーす、速報です速報です
結果はっ！
はいっ
２５．７
なんともいえねえ
普通のスポーツテスト確か2回だったよね
じゃあもう一回ずつやりましょう
おｋ
次でよかった方の記録が
正規の記録です
本気でいきたいと思います
あ、いいじゃん
ほうほうほう
７か
結果出ました！
速報です！
結果
２２．７ｍ
おっけい
うわぁ、うわ危ねっ
どこどこ？
んん？
速報です！
速報です
結果
２９．１
うああっしゃあぁ↗
うざいうざいうざい
負けられないということで
目標はっ！？
おおー！
夢の30m超えですね
ここ３２！
いきますっ！
やばい
速報です！速報でーす！
結果がでましたー
結果は
はい
３０．６！
でぇええん！！
♬～
意外とYoutuber
腕は使うので
ぜひYoutuberの皆さん
ハンドボール投げしてみてはいかがでしょうか
じゃあな！